[Music]
foreign
[Music]
an economic world power that presents
itself not only through his far-reaching
culture but also through his
forward-looking technology
in many areas of Industry China is one
of the leading countries but the country
does not seem to be open to all new
technologies the crypto industry with
its miners seem to be a thorn in the
economic power side China has banned all
crypto transactions and also announced
that it will stop the mining of digital
assets the most severe blow to the
industry so far
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
the People's Republic of China is not
enthusiastic when it comes to the
cryptocurrency stars and especially the
number one Bitcoin has had a long
intense dispute with China since its
invention
trading the world's oldest
cryptocurrency is not welcome in the
People's Republic of China after all it
was China that helped Bitcoin achieve
its current Fame
finally it is thanks to the numerous
pioneers and miners from China that
countries like Salvador or Venezuela
offer Bitcoin as an alternative means of
payment
nevertheless the Chinese government's
negative attitude towards cryptocurrency
has become increasingly clear and
incisive over time
but the Chinese authorities are going
even further in their efforts to
suppress crypto trading crypto
transactions are considered illegal
Financial activities including services
offered by offshore exchanges The
People's Bank of China reported on its
website it added that cryptocurrencies
including Bitcoin and tether are not
real fiat currency and thus cannot be in
circulation
Bitcoin crashed after the announcement
calling eight percent to around 43 000.
fraud money laundering and excessive
energy use are all associated with
cryptocurrencies the enormous energy
consumption of crypto mining is also a
reason why the entire crypto industry is
under scrutiny
the Chinese economic planning Authority
explained that it was their job to take
tough action and stop crypto mining in
order not to jeopardize the government's
set climate targets
China is facing a severe energy crisis
that has already affected Commodities
such as aluminum and steel
the country hosts about 50 percent of
the world's crypto Miners and had a 46
share of the global hash rate a measure
of the computing power used in mining
and processing
will Bitcoin and the crypto industry
succeed without China
what do the analysis and crypto industry
experts have to say about the latest
development in China
let's get back to China's increasing
Crackdown on crypto it looks like
they've gone absolute at this point
saying on the pboc website they will ban
all transactions or that all crypto
transactions are illegal we do see
bitcoin's price falling down below 44
000 down below 43 000 right now 42 912.
let's get to Joanna ossinger our Asia
crypto Czar for more on what this
actually means um Joanna it seems like
from now on everything that you want to
do besides simply holding crypto if you
already have it is illegal is that the
am I reading this correctly
hi Matt that's kind of what it looks
like but the question always with these
things from China is what does it mean
in practice you know we've had the
crackdowns before over the years and
people have been able to do workarounds
and able to keep exchanges going even
though they they crack down on exchanges
there are a lot of people who still hold
crypto so you'll see even for Bitcoin
and the crypto complex generally the
drop that we've seen is actually not
that big so it tells you that it's not
that much of a surprise but it's
definitely not being you know it it's
definitely not increasing the prices
either right
so Jenna why are they doing this now
they've been wanting to do it do they
feel emboldened by everything else is it
a distraction because of what's going on
with evergrand
it might be that they're they're seeing
you know the SEC in the U.S is cracking
down on things as well they are seeing
other Regulators taking steps but you
know China does things when it does them
right so it's a little bit hard to tell
exactly it could be that they're
concerned about something with Evergreen
but it could just be that they're
looking at crypto overall and saying
this is the time when we want to take
this step because they've been going at
it you know since before ever Grand was
really getting people's attention
yeah is there concern by the way that
um retail investors are going to get
burned speculating in this uh asset or
is there concern that wealthy Chinese
people are going to use it to move
um wealth offshore
but there is um speculation that it's
it's both of these things and actually
one thing to watch with this would be
tether which is seen as key in terms of
flows into crypto from China and
recently it was looking at prices it's
about 99.1 cents and it's usually a
dollar so that will be interesting with
insight and Analysis let's get straight
to Eddie Van Der Walt our great crypto
Watcher Bloomberg M live strategies so
Eddie good morning first of all we're
trying to figure out exactly how for how
much further this goes right they China
had already declared a war on bitcoin
absolutely and this seems to be a step
further in trying to ban it completely
look it does feel like an escalation
doesn't it if they are really saying no
transactions I would like to know
exactly what that means does that mean I
cannot buy with it or does it mean that
I can't transact with you I cannot send
you Bitcoin from my phone to your phone
into you know so so that I can no longer
trade it on an exchange so I'm I'm still
a little bit on what it means what a
transaction is in this particular
circumstances and how strictly they'll
enforce it but it is confirmation China
doesn't like this and Bitcoin at the
moment still needs China and Chinese
investors you know there's a lot of
Chinese investors that have been long
Bitcoin and have been using it and have
been building it up so it's an
escalation and and we shall see how much
you know crypto prices respond to it
yeah I think it's interesting
um Francine makes a good point that
they've incrementally been fighting
again they banned exchanges they banned
mining but it looks like what they're
saying is and the emphasis is on the
word all all crypto related transactions
are illegal
to me that means anytime you want to
trade it be it for goods and services or
trading with friends any kind of crypto
related transactions are legal and I
mean just looking at the price it
doesn't seem to have hit Bitcoin that
hard right now we're looking at a drop
of three percent if still 43 351 how
important is the Chinese market to
bitcoin
the Chinese market is extremely
important and you know the question is
well how how well China will be able to
enforce this I do Wonder though Matt
whether this is whether we are talking
about a ban of transactions or a ban of
ownership because if we if we if
ownership is still legal then
effectively you will have to be able to
trade it somehow but if it's about
transactions and I won't be able to pay
for goods and services with it then it's
an escalation but not as serious as it
as it had been right because then it is
no longer a financial instrument either
which it for the most part let's face it
Bitcoin is not used that much for
transacting in the financial system it
is used as a financial asset
it puts it it puts it really in a gray
area this is like in the U.S this was
the issue with marijuana a lot in a lot
of States you could own it you could
hold it but you weren't allowed to buy
it or sell it so the question was how do
I get it well um the law didn't make
that clear they just said you cannot buy
buy it or sell it but you can hold it
and that may be the same case with
Bitcoin here
well it's clear it's clear which way the
direction of travel is here in China
right I think that for me is the message
I we know that China is not keen on
cryptocurrencies in general particularly
ones that they don't control so you know
uh Central Bank digital asset will be a
completely different thing but but but
but for the for the for the wide
spectrum of cryptocurrencies I don't
think that they have made it clear that
this is not something that they like
Eddie the Crackdown in China is not
unfortunately limited to
cryptocurrencies they've been cracking
down really as our Tom McKenzie put it
to us on risk across the board and that
includes in the property sector which
raises the Evergreen question we have no
idea what happened with the dollar
coupon Bond payment yesterday whether or
not they actually met that deadline what
happens in the next 24-48 hours
from from China and in general I I think
we we we have to wait and see we have to
wait and see whether there is any
contagion that comes from this and yes I
think you know the Chinese system it it
it it's it's uncomfortable bed fellows
with uh with with capitalism in general
and therefore you know it's it's a it's
a hard case for them to make
um in general that you know trading and
and free markets and letting people
speculate as much as they want to so
some sort of Crackdown is is possible
but but for the ever Grand Fallout I
think it is possible that you know that
China contains this it is not an it's
not something that they can that they
cannot prevent the spillovers if they
wanted to so you know whether with a
particular bondholders will lose money
that isn't but one question but they can
stop the financial system from seizing
up
China is well aware of the potential of
blockchain technology and has even
introduced its own digital currency the
digital Iran also the Chinese company
tencent had already launched a program
called qcoin in 2007 which was used in
its own messaging service QQ and also
opened its own secondary Market
as a result in 2009 the Chinese
government banned the use of digital
currencies for the purchase of real
goods and services Bitcoin was one of
them but was not explicitly mentioned in
the ban
However the fact that the Chinese
population already has experience with
digital currencies worked in their favor
China has therefore became the center of
the young crypto industry over the years
meanwhile the Chinese government decided
to wait for the development of digital
coin which in turn open up opportunities
for crypto companies to explore in new
ways
the first Chinese Bitcoin exchange BTC
China was founded in 2011 followed by
the crypto platform's Hobby and bitmain
in 2013 with companies such as Baidu
immediately accepting Bitcoin payments
this in turn attracted the attention of
China's currency regulators
in December 2013 they announced that
Chinese financial institutions would no
longer be allowed to process Bitcoin
transactions they declared Bitcoin and
illegal means of payment
this announcement came at a time when
Bitcoin trading had already taken off
considerably and the Bitcoin price
exceeded the one thousand dollar Mark
for the first time almost 10 days before
the ban
after the announcement bitcoin's value
on the world's largest Bitcoin exchange
at the time crashed by over 30 percent
or crypto industry insiders China's
crypto ban did not come as a complete
surprise Bitcoin mining however was
excluded from the ban this was still
allowed and favorable conditions quickly
made China and El Dorado a Bitcoin
mining companies
although the regulator did not prevent
individuals from Trading Bitcoin they
advised those involved to be aware of
the associated risks
[Music]
we know that China has been taking steps
in this direction but this is incredibly
dramatic I mean what is your take on
this what does this mean for even a
company like Falcon X
sure so you know I think China has been
Banning cryptocurrency for a number of
years now first in 2013 2017 this is not
the first time they've done so this year
and for an authoritarian regime that's
trying to promote their digital one and
keeping in mind that the China national
holiday is next week their Crackdown on
crypto is what I would really align with
senator Pat Toomey a big opportunity for
the United States and a reminder of our
structural advantage over China in terms
of you know just what we've seen
historically to what Ed mentioned this
definitely wasn't as large of a move as
we've seen uh you know prior times in
Market movements we see a rad candle
stick down and panic initially followed
by quick buyback and Market recovery for
BTC largely buy side uh led by
asia-based hedge funds and for U.S
institutions across a number of personas
and for eth we're seeing a much larger
hit with a much slower buyback uh driven
by proprietary funds who are the winners
and losers here and and if you could get
into some coins specifically you know
that would certainly help us better
understand the situation
yeah that's a really really good
question you know I think uh what we
were seeing it was
you know a slower last two months
historically uh for us on the volume
side we saw it seven times more volume
today
um than we had seen across you know a
number of weeks where we had a lot of
conferences both in traditional finance
and cryptocurrency uh layer ones are
definitely top of mind I know uh you've
spoken
um you know about uh layer ones
historically in the past you know
ethereum but also uh things like
Avalanche Solana uh Adam as well as Luna
um in addition to bitcoin uh and then
some tokens outside of that uh primarily
looking at uh renewed interests and some
of the play to earn tokens like a ygg or
an axi infinity
and you know China is saying they're
going to investigate anyone working for
overseas cryptocurrency exchanges as
well would any Falcon X employees fall
under that umbrella I mean what does
this mean for your employees and the way
that you operate as a company
yeah so Falcon X today uh we do have
offices uh in the U.S as well as our
Asia office uh in India so not a direct
impact to our business but I think
that's definitely top of mind for for
any business uh that may have any
employees sitting in in China as you
mentioned
now if you know obviously this is
happening in Asia which which used to be
sort of the center of crypto Innovation
we're preparing for tougher regulation
here in the United States we're
preparing for tougher regulation on
crypto in Europe if that's the case and
you see a broad-based Crackdown then
where do you think the growth is going
to come from
yeah that's a really good question I
think you know if we use just China
mining as an example of this uh we saw
China ban Mining and we actually saw a
number of those miners come to the
United States so hash rate is almost 70
percent of what it was prior to the ban
so we've almost has a full comeback uh
from that and a lot of the minors today
are in the U.S and so uh we really saw
that Innovation come to the United
States and again going back to that
really an opportunity for the US to show
that we're at the Forefront of working
uh with this industry uh to spark
Innovation I think across the board
everyone's trying to protect consumers
that is top of mind for any company in
this space how do we do so without
stifling innovation
in 2015 Chinese Bitcoin mining companies
made up half of the Bitcoin hash rate
the first additional cryptocurrencies to
be exchanged through so-called initial
coin offerings Ico with those of the
digital currency
[Music]
in Autumn 2017 Chinese icos has raised
over 400 million dollars alerting the
Chinese government
in an attempt to support the weakening
Yuen and prevent the illegal outflow of
money from China the country's Central
Bank began investigating the activities
of crypto exchanges in January 2017.
as a result the investigation focused on
the stock exchanges approach to a
foreign exchange management and
anti-money laundering
[Music]
the pboc considered icos to be an
illegal fundraising mechanism a ban Ico
platforms from issuing Ico tokens and
ordered that the funds raised through
icos should be returned to investors
among other things the regulator found
that icos threatened the stability of
the country's economy and pose a risk of
business failure the order also
stipulated that financial institutions
and non-bank payment companies may not
offer services that support token-based
fundraising activities
while China's crypto Community was still
processing this new reality Regulators
issued another directive
only two weeks later crypto exchanges
that allowed the exchange of Fiat to
cryptocurrency were definitively banned
as a result many Bitcoin platforms moved
their activities abroad While others
were forced to close their platforms
completely
what did you think when you heard about
China's move
I think you know we've seen the
resiliency of the crypto markets uh to
sort of changing regulation uh and
specifically changing regulation in
China several times before uh it's very
hard to eventually predict you know how
any change impacts the The Gatekeepers
or the various players in the market but
it's very clear that it's impossible to
regulate Bitcoin itself as the protocol
and people's usage of sort of the
decentralized protocol whether it's
Bitcoin or others I think in general
there's a lot of discussion about the
fact that you know in September
2017 there was also sort of the big
China ban on crypto on exchanges and
after that we saw sort of the first big
crypto rally of 2017 of Bitcoin reaching
back then the records of a
2017. I think you know sometimes when
you think about regulating Bitcoin it's
like you know a multiple-headed monster
you try to cut his head and then you get
five additional heads so it's very
interesting to see that resiliency of
the protocol itself yeah you definitely
just called Bitcoin Hydra but that's
cool we'll just go with that um but to
your point that's going to be the Bull's
point that there's going to be lots of
different Avenues and lots of different
people who want to wind up trading
Bitcoin if China really cracks down and
says you can't own it which they didn't
say but say they say you can't own it
you can't use it at all and you can't
trade it how does that not have a
material impact on the price and the
volume that it can trade with
you know like I think the global economy
as a global economy is much bigger than
any single state we're seeing a
transition globally by the way in
capital markets as well from Capital
markets being a hyper local where people
only trade locally to Capital markets
being Global and then obviously crypto
markets are hyper Global the opposite of
local Capital markets uh there's
definitely you know there's always going
to be impact of various regulations in
the crypto Market but I think we'll also
see the again the resilience of a global
monetary decentralized system and
there's going to be a shift that we
started seeing you know an exciting
shift this year more towards D5 to
decentralized finance to various
protocols I think this will shift the
industry more towards D5
of course the potential bigger risk for
cryptocurrencies uh and I think Yoni we
may agree that other cryptocurrencies
are the bigger threat to uh to central
banks uh rather than Bitcoin which is
kind of in a class of its own for better
or worse but the risk is the other
central banks notably the Federal
Reserve uh and certainly the ECB
weighing in and actually deciding how
and when and what form these things can
trade and whether the central banks want
their own Fiat based digital currency
which could happen how big a risk is
that is that some of what we're seeing
priced in here
so you know as always I'm an optimist so
any risk is an opportunity there's no
doubt we're seeing you know the the
Genies out of the bottle we're seeing
the digitization of money we're seeing
digital transformation happening to
money which is the biggest digital
transformation of everything and I think
the blockchain technology represents
that shift Bitcoin represents a new type
of global commodity uh and Regulators uh
will look for ways to regulate and
governments to innovate uh I think we'll
see a lot of central banks and
governments launching their own digital
currencies I think this will run in
parallel to what we call today the
crypto market so the difference it's a
different type of an asset uh but I
think you know this process of moving
the entire monetary system into the
digital realm is definitely something
sort of an arms race between a lot of
different countries around the world
yeah any last question here quickly
um since China made announcement what
kind of trading have you seen on your
platform
well we generally see a trading patterns
sort of really reflect with volatility
so as volatility is higher we see more
trading activity and with price goes up
so you know we've seen in May that
correction that lowered prices of
Bitcoin from all-time high after the
mining Ben then we've seen an Awakening
on a lot of the D5 protocols in the
beginning of August which sort of
revived a lot of new protocols as well
as bitcoin price and eth reaching almost
4 000 again uh and I think now with that
correction we're seeing markets that are
a bit softer than they were a month ago
as a result of such developments some
China based exchanges relocated their
operations to other countries While
others had to close their businesses in
April 2019 China's national development
and Reform Commission ndrc identified
Bitcoin mining as an undesirable
industry in its preliminary list of
sectors that should be promoted
restricted or eliminated by local
governments Bitcoin mining a computer
intensive process of validating Bitcoin
transactions in order to receive newly
coined Bitcoin as a reward built into
the catalog of Industry that the agency
deemed particularly harmful to the
environment as might be expected this
move caused some Panic given that a
significant percentage of Bitcoin mining
rigs were made in China moreover more
than half of the world's Bitcoin mining
power was located in China as operators
there had access to cheap electricity
although the ndrc eventually dropped
Bitcoin mining from his final draft
after much deliberation the whole
episode was an initial step of what was
to come talk us through some of these
these latest lines coming out from China
how is this different why do you think
the market was quick to shrug it off
yeah good morning Yvonne so good to be
back the the latest ban is just an
extension of further tightening of the
crypto policies in China uh this has
been rumored since the summer time that
China will eventually get cut off in
terms of the crypto exchanges Market as
people may know four years ago the pboc
and The Regulators banned domestic
exchanges in China
and then what happened was many of the
exchanges just moved offshore but yet
we're still servicing people within
mainland China by requiring them to go
through VPN access and so on so this
band when you talk about crypto
transactions I think there's a slight
mistranslation it's really emphasized
about crypto buying and selling the
crypto purchasing the crypto exchange
transactions that happen on the exchange
platforms so I believe that private
exchange is private buy sells are still
allowed it's just that the
enterprise-led exchanges that action is
now deemed um
you know illegal and they were prosecute
so this is why the recently in the
recent last two days the major exchange
platforms around China have all
announced the stopping of registration
of Chinese users
why do you think China continues to
double down on this Bobby is it still
concerns about money laundering and what
you know crypto can actually the risk
that it could bring or is it more
broadened now is it about energy
consumption or even the threat of a
digital a threat to the digital remnb
what do you think is motivating Beijing
yeah I think it has to do with the
controlled currency as you know you know
in a in a controlled regime with uh with
Forex uh you know controlled foreign
currencies they really don't want any
loopholes where people can use a digital
currency vehicle to move assets abroad
so I think that's the main reason is
just to retain the control over the
economy the control of the finances uh
and the outflow of money the influent
outflow of money but in the end it's not
it's not about energy I think they
banned the mining of crypto earlier this
year for the purpose of alignment with
all of the crypto the timing ban but as
I've said before this is actually not
the file final nail in the coffin which
would be the so-called making crypto
assets illegal to hold as well so that
clearly has not happened yet
we've reported for from weeks and months
now about minors in China that are just
packing up their bags and going are you
able to track I mean you're on the
ground in Shanghai how much activity has
actually shifted out of the country now
so much of the traditional what they
call proof of power uh cryptocurrency
mining that has moved abroad so this
would be like the Bitcoin the Litecoin
and the ethereum uh there's a new
category of mining where it involves
proof of stake where it involves like
storage uh the likes of file coin and
other derivatives those are still
happening in China because it's much
harder to detect these are machines that
are regular computers with storage you
know solid state drives and so on and a
lot of that activity is still happening
in China but it's hard to really
classify that as traditional proof of
power proof of work uh mining
so Bobby just talk us through in terms
of what your outlook is right now you
talked about you know
similar crackdowns we've seen from from
Beijing has led to a boom when it comes
to bitcoin prices is this time very much
the same you think
yeah it's it's kind of like you know
when the rumor when the rumor is uh so
what does it sell on rumor bound news
that's kind of what's happening right
now the rumor has been in the works for
several months now that China will have
very tight Crackdown on bitcoin this
year
and the you know the hammer finally
dropped uh the timing is is reminiscent
of what happened in 2017
when the Crackdown came in September in
early September and then of course we
knew that the Bitcoin prices rallied to
a multi-year high uh at the end of 2017
and this year no different that uh with
a Crackdown now announced sort of the
bad news in that out of the way uh the
market is reacting and processing
digesting that information I think I I'm
very bullish on bitcoin especially for
end-of-year rally a fomo rally this year
so I expect Bitcoin prices to break out
again uh in the next few weeks and
months
all right we're still hovering around
that 43 000 level we tumbled below uh
that kind of level there over the
weekend
the all yeah I'm just wondering what
what you know we're still far from that
all-time high around 60 63 000. I mean
what do you think prices are really
going to go if you're talking about
year-end rallies now
so I uh I think you'll easily go over
100 000 and then depending on how sharp
the rally is it's also likely to even
touch 200 or even go above that now
obviously going above 200 200 000 is a
huge milestone so there'll be a lot of
uh media coverage and that's what leads
to a
what they call fear of missing out rally
so generally that happens every few
years and I think uh you know a fomo
rally for Bitcoin has been due for a
long time now
I mean we would probably maybe just at
the end we've seen this regulatory
Crackdown in China from everything from
fintech to cryptos
does it change in any way how you
operate now uh and your business with
ballet
yeah my business is selling Hardware
wallets so we are not impacted by this
and also you know for this being my
second startup from the outset I knew to
position our business to not rely on the
China market so after the earlier
Crackdown our sales in China have indeed
come down but for me it's not a big
issue because we've always relied on the
international Global Market for
cryptocurrency so for for wallet makers
and other businesses that don't
concentrate their activity in China this
Crackdown doesn't make a difference
however for those companies that are
focused on the China Market I think this
is tougher for them
following the state council's
declaration provincial governments began
taking proactive measures to stop crypto
mining The Regulators Justified the new
action mainly on the grounds that
Bitcoin is very energy intensive and
poses a threat to the country's
environmental goals the fact that the
crypto industry is intensively searching
for a more environmentally friendly
version of Bitcoin has already been
presented with the China Green token
project
Chia has been dubbed the green altcoin
how exactly is it greener than Bitcoin
well first of all instead of relying on
electricity and custom Hardware to prove
that you're correctly validating the
chain we instead rely on unused hard
drive space and what you do is you fill
your space with what is the equivalent
of a bingo card and you just store it on
your drive until you happen to win that
challenge and get the chance to validate
a transaction and hard drives use
significantly less power if all the hard
drives that we're going to ship this
year a whole is that a byte worth we're
compared to just say ethereum that's
like one-tenth the total energy usage
per year
so if Chia really takes off though then
doesn't that create a need for more
storage and need for more hard drives
which ultimately creates more waste and
then that's another problem for the
environment well if there's two things
that are important here thing one is you
know better than what you know a bicycle
is much more efficient than a Tesla but
that doesn't mean that we don't want
Teslas to compete with SUVs we are a
much Greener alternative with more
Security in fact than both Bitcoin and
ethereum we have about 500 000 nodes
compared to Bitcoins 40 000 nodes but
actually what we're doing is we're
putting used hard drives back in service
you in Facebook or box uh gets to the
four-year end-of-life of those drives
they get sold recyclers and what's been
happening as far Farmers been buying
those and instead of them going to a
landfill or farming them
so you just announced plans to go public
and as I understand it the plan is to
become an exchange a broader payment
system can you talk to us about what the
overall Ambitions are
yeah we believe that blockchain should
have gotten product Market fit in 2017
but there were regulatory problems and
the functionality that was available on
most chains really wasn't yet ready for
Enterprise or government adoption our
new on-chain programming environment Q
lisp is very much designed to support
things like Central Bank digital
currencies uh distributed exchanges so
things like carbon credit markets later
equities and one of the things we did
very differently is we've taken the
company form to you know Drive the
adoption of a blockchain we expect to
build kind of a red hat business where
we're supporting the adoption of
blockchain infrastructure for the people
who need it and our strategy to go
public is very much a product strategy
for for a lot of companies going public
as an exit for us it actually helps
clarify the regulations it kind of makes
it more clear that this is our Equity
versus these are our coins which are a
commodity and it also allows our users
to for example use our Equity to Shield
themselves from some of the coin
volatility that these coins often have
now there's been some backlash against
Chia for being a for-profit company
backlash around the timing of the IPO
um chia's founder Bram Cohen also the
inventor of bit torrent recently tweeted
I'd like to emphasize we aren't selling
any tokens have raised money under
normal investment terms and chia is not
a security some community members are
being obnoxiously entitled and should
knock it off what's your response to the
pushback we are trying we are trying to
build a real community of Civility and
actual interest in the technology you
know this is a 30-plus year opportunity
and we're no rush to try to be there
first what we want to do is to actually
go and solve the real problems people
have things like being able to transfer
money between Banks into different
countries things like sending money home
to Guatemala you know these things
should be easier to do than cash they
should be cheaper than they currently
are and those are the things we're
really focused on you know there
certainly is a bit of a gold rush effect
where people want want to get in and get
in early for Chia farming and chia
farming is very approachable it's not
super easy not yet and we will make it
easier but I think there's some
frustration and especially around uh
detail which is pooling allowing people
to kind of share their rewards but we're
going to have that for people very
shortly
you say it's greater than Bitcoin is it
greener than ethereum too
so the thing about ethereum too is that
well it's going to be available in three
months for the last two years we don't
think proof of stake is actually secure
when you start talking about inner
government kind of competitions proof of
stake has all sorts of problems that
really Nakamoto consensus which is what
Bitcoin is in which we are evolved from
really fixed you know there are problems
like every proof of stake chain is
available for 50.1 percent of the value
of the chain and if you were to buy it
you own it for the future where like
Bitcoin or Chia can recover from a 51
attack and keep going
now obviously there's been a lot of
volatility in the crypto Market in
general but there's bit the Chia coin
itself has been super volatile since
launch what do you make of that well I
think it was trying to find a price uh
and you know I think it has now found a
price if you kind of look at over the
last two weeks it's been in a well call
it 600 to 1100 range in crypto that's a
narrow range for other folks that's not
as usual a range that they're used to
I want to ask you one last question
about Elon Musk you mentioned Tesla
earlier and obviously Elon Musk has had
a lot of influence on price fluctuations
over the last several weeks do you think
that's a good thing or that is that
unhealthy
well you know I think at least Elon was
looking at the right issues which are
that cryptocurrency is uh the way of the
future but that there are real concerns
around the carbon footprint that
ethereum and Bitcoin have today
um but you know I will say it this way
celebrities will be celebrities you know
we're very much more focused on actually
getting this blockchain adopted by real
users
so you think he's just a celebrity
well certainly not in the rocket
business or in the car business or the
solar business but in the blockchain
space uh you know I I like the joke uh
he once tweeted that uh he wanted
blockchains to be 10 times faster and 10
times cheaper and I'm hoping that my
plaid Model S is going to be 10 times
cheaper too foreign
of environmental sustainability is not
the only key to success
China keeps providing environmental
reasons to introduce more regulations
and above all which countries are
leading in this respect
is finding an answer to the
environmental sustainability part of the
pace really crucial here
good morning thanks for having me on the
show it's great to be here honey and you
know I think this is a really important
question for for all Industries uh and
and you know crypto is no uh is not
excluded from that Set uh you know we
don't stand alone so I you know I think
the the really interesting thing about
crypto is that it's a it's an almost
kind of
um marginal efficiency uh maximalist so
it is seeking the lower sources of power
and we know that Renewables are so you
know the latest stats that I've seen at
that crypto miners uh in particular
Bitcoin mining which has the most impost
um is is or in the 50s to sixty percent
range for use of Renewables which is
well above you know industry averages
that being said it it's it is a long way
to go there and and I think it is a key
part of the story for crypto because you
know this latest uh band from China
which you mentioned one of several that
we've seen
um it's you know
that's driven I think from from maybe
they're tied up but I think you know the
the China van has is it's part of a
bigger story uh for China in general and
and it's something that we're you know
obviously not happy to see but but from
the energy point of view
um what that has meant and the previous
bands in China for mining you know
earlier this year has been that binding
has moved uh offshore it it's now you
know accounts for only 45 of mining is
in China and that will likely uh likely
reduce over time and and the more that
mining moves offshore out of China and
the more that it moves into places where
there's faster and faster uptake of
Renewables uh and uh that the US is one
of those locales uh we'll see the that
Energy Mix Change for for crypto uh and
the last thing I'll say on this is that
um the the different blockchains that
exist out there you know Bitcoin is one
of them um you might have heard of uh
ethereum I'm sure
um these are they're looking at
alternative ways to secure the network
and and so proof of stake which is a
it's a different method for for uh
securing these transactions actions and
securing the distributed Ledger it a lot
of new technologies new coins and
existing coins are transitioning to this
type of methodology and I think that
will have an impact
yeah I was going to ask you about proof
of stake because even with the proof of
stake blockchains they're not created
equally right in theorem he actually
ranks pretty poorly out of some of the
others is it really kind of the
environmental savior here
it's part of the story I think the main
uh the the the the Savior here is is uh
generation needs to change to Renewables
and and uh crypto will move uh even
faster because we know that uh you know
renewable energy is the cheapest source
of energy now uh and and every new
project in fact there are some
Australian projects that are a really
quite interesting modular mining
projects they're part of the they can
actually empower the energy transition I
think you know crypto being something
that can be located crypto miners that
is can be located on site uh we're
seeing projects that are you know uh
setting up on site dealing with excess
excess Supply you know we've got excess
supply issues in Australia when it comes
to Peak uh Peak solar in the middle of
the day and you can leverage some
modular consumption here so so bitcoin's
not not just the enemy it's part of it's
part of a transition and it's quite an
interesting tool in that but the real
issue is Generation and we're seeing
that change and I think crypto will
follow
we have seen this new experiment of a
cross-border digital currency by the
bank of international settlements not to
mention the monetary authorities of
China and Hong Kong what will digital
currencies do to other crypto assets
it's a really interesting question
because you know we've we've seen the
announcement recently that you know
platforms like Twitter uh have have
added crypto to their to their to their
Network you can tip people on on the
platform using using Bitcoin and there
was some really interesting videos
showing showing people uh tipping uh
cross-border so all of a sudden you know
Twitter is now a a cross-border uh
payments platform as well as a social
media Network and and that's the power
of blockchain and crypto it's native to
the internet and it can plug into any
app so I think that the rise of Central
Bank digital currencies is also that's
something interesting but what has been
proven over the last 12 to 24 months
um by the rise of uh stable coins and
the use of crypto and cross-border flows
is that it's it's a superior form of
money it it works better in that in that
context and so you're going to see uh
central banks take you make use of that
technology you know it's the new
internet it's a new rail so so these
things will coexist unfortunately in a
place like China that they're trying to
enforce uh one one type of currency
we've seen we've seen the attitudes to
Tech and general and that's an
unfortunate thing for I think for
emergent businesses in the Chinese
Community there who are who are so quick
to embrace new technology right so you
know crypto and and Central Bank digital
currencies will coexist in the future
when it comes to embracing new
technologies uh developing their digital
currencies and perhaps the development
of regulations as well which countries
are leading
uh I mean we're kraken's a really proud
U.S domicile business and we have a a
footprint here in Australia we've got a
local footprint here and in many other
countries and and different countries
have different flavors and the
regulatory framework is something that's
um that shifts and changes and and so
and that and that has a big part to play
in terms of adoption right now if you're
gonna if you're going to tell me who the
most um uh Advanced uh crypto uh
countries are you you can't not mention
um countries that have adopted it as
legal tender like El Salvador but you
know there's there's so much Innovation
coming out of of Europe coming out um of
Switzerland where there's a lot of uh
domiciles uh foundations for some of the
the most interesting Technologies the US
has a huge amount of uh vibrant and
exciting projects it's a it's a global
technology and and where the people are
whether people are is what matters and
interestingly there's some really
fascinating projects coming out of
Australia as well
for most of 2020 the Chinese government
was tightening its grip on
cryptocurrency Exchange activities
within its border as part of an ongoing
campaign to fight money laundering and
fraud in August the pboc announced its
intention to block over 100 foreign
websites offering crypto exchanges the
problem facing China's crypto industry
in 2021 began in May when the state
Council doubled down on previous crypto
policies by calling for restrictions on
crypto Mining and trading previously
provincial authorities in the inner
Mongolia xinjiang and Sichuan provinces
all of which were major Bitcoin mining
hubs had begun to introduce measures
restricting the operation of Bitcoin
miners similar to the prosecution of
crypto Exchange in 2017 Bitcoin miners
were forced to either permanently stop
operating or relocate to other crypto
friendly countries since around 50 of
the world's Bitcoin mining output was
generated in China before demand the
global Bitcoin economy filled impact of
China's Bitcoin mining ban as expected
just give us your take about Beijing
walking away from crypto assets
good morning and thank you very much for
having me well even if you take it aside
from the whole crypto issue I think as a
soft power move this may perhaps be a
misstep from China
as countries you know that are trying to
be within its sphere of influence if you
look at that because of El Salvador if
you look at Laos if you look at
Afghanistan those are all countries that
are moving towards the use of
cryptocurrency just as China is pulling
back now where that's concerning for the
Chinese is that they've put so much
effort into their soft Powers
um you know their Outreach they've been
conducting globally particularly if you
look at their efforts that they've done
in Latin America and as they're putting
back in these countries and regions are
moving in that's going to cause a
problem for them download mine yeah we
have seen even FTX The Exchange decision
to move its headquarters from Hong Kong
to the Bahamas those moves to latam as
you mentioned what does this mean
practically speaking for all of these
companies that have relations with China
Chinese users as well
oh that's true if you look at both Hobby
and okx okay exchange to well-known
behemoths from China that trading crypto
we saw the impact on their token in
trading over the weekend both experience
considerable drops in value and and
certainly for companies that have that
exposure to China with Chinese clients
will be scrambling over the weekend and
onwards to try and withdraw their
positions it is of deep concern for
anyone with that level of exposure but I
think what's important is to frame it
within the crypto industry itself the
industry has proven its robustness time
and again this is the second time this
year that China has effectively tried to
ban crypto and the fourth time since
2013. yes absolutely the industry saw a
drop off in bitcoin price in June when
the last ban came through but we can see
what happened in the months subsequent
and if you look at trading over the
course of the weekend in Bitcoin yes
there was an impact as you would expect
but we're also reading off the back of
what's happening with evergre brand and
The Wider implications there what
instead this tells us is further proof
of the robustness when it comes to
cryptocurrency particularly as it takes
its place and the global stage so I
think that um for us we're looking at
what happens in China with great
interest but equally and with certain
measure we're looking at what's
happening out of the US and where
they're taking their regulation
particularly considering how you know
the pivot that we've seen over the
course of this year Westward towards
Bitcoin mining and regulation overall so
yes absolutely if I was a company that
had exposure to China and I was related
to to cryptocurrency I would be
concerned however the rest of this wider
industry we're rolling with the punches
and Caroline you take a look at the
long-term uh Trend Direction when it
comes to bitcoin right we're still
pretty far off the all-time high of
above 60 000. uh do you see that market
recovery and how much of it has really
priced in the news out of China given
yes it is more severe but we have been
hearing variations of this sentiment
since about 2019.
yeah absolutely I think you know I think
the price tip that we saw is probably
indicative I mean there was it was less
than 10 of things
five to seven percent drop off over the
weekend and the price but counter that
then with the other news that came out
with regards to Twitter we'd have said
it will now allow its users to send and
receive Bitcoin so while you've got the
negative coming out of China you're also
on the other hand have got 330 million
Twitter users you will now be able to
use Bitcoin um as part of the social
media transactions so it's certainly you
know kind of climbing it in its
ascendancy do I think we're going to see
in the sixty thousand dollar price point
again the trend would suggest that
that's a direction that we're heading in
do I think over the longer term that
we're going to see the use case for
Bitcoin absolutely but I think anyone
would be
um rather foolhardy to say that this is
it this is the one and only I think that
time has shown Us in history and human
civilization has shown us that we like
to change what we use as a method of
value exchange and certainly I would
imagine that for Bitcoin there's going
to be many Pretenders to its crown
so when it comes to Australia of course
there's been lots of criticisms from
within the crypto industry that
regulation or I guess a nurturing
ecosystem has fallen behind compared to
other places like Singapore or even
parts of the Middle East right do you
expect is there to be a more fruitful
conversation about cryptocurrency or is
there a chance that we'll see some of
these jurisdictions taking China's lead
well this is the real opportunity for
Australia and this is certainly a
message that the industry has been
trying to deliver to both government and
regulators and we wait with interest to
see the report that's due to come out
from the Senate
um this month actually sorry in October
next month this is the real opportunity
with China retreating from the field
there is a chance now for countries such
as Australia to really step forward
we've also got the opportunity when it
comes to a kind of the green mining of
Bitcoin with all the green Energy
Solutions that are available here if you
look at the opportunity for example that
Iran has taken it now contributes 4.5 of
Bitcoin mining globally according to
figures releasing elliptic that shows
the opportunity that is there that other
nations are stepping forward but we then
have to ask ourselves do we want this uh
to come out of countries such as Iran El
Salvador et cetera or do we feel as
though there's an opportunity for
Australia to step forward particularly
when you look at other local countries
to us here in Asia Pacific if you look
at where Singapore has been going
um in particular which has been very
much a beacon for the industry I think
there's there's an opportunity for
greater partnership collaboration and
supposed to find the Australian way
forward with this um and certainly you
know that's something that industry is
very strongly pushing forward
China also trying to hammer down on some
of the crypto mining How do prices
respond
it has been an incredibly volatile week
for for Bitcoin in this latest news from
China just really hammered it again
um it's the second time this week that
news out of China has really impacted
the cryptocurrency First with it saying
that it wouldn't allow financial
institutions to to use it and we're
going to crack down on it more and now
with this latest news about cracking
down on mining and it's it's really
thrown the cryptocurrency for another
loop yeah I mean this is testing a lot
of folks out there uh and good thing
crypto doesn't trade on weekends right
it's a trick question
I wish that
oh I just I I wish that uh that
cryptocurrency
um took a break on the weekends but yeah
it continues to trade and so this
weekend we might even see uh more
volatile moves just given that usually
on weekends um there is lighter volumes
and so sometimes we see even more
volatility then Claire we love though
that it trades on weekends that means
that you as a reporter have a job on
Saturday and Sunday which we know that
you love talk to us though about it just
in terms of how we think about this
going forward when you get comments from
China any little pause really makes the
currency or the crypto space so volatile
what does this mean really going forward
well it seems like the only thing that's
certain is that you know volatility
probably will continue for Bitcoin
um from what I've heard talking with
investors is that around these movements
with Bitcoin it it does impact the
broader Market in a way obviously not
the main factor but I think it's hard
for
um investors trading stocks and bonds to
see how Wild Things Are with Bitcoin and
not be impacted somehow and so we have
seen a bit of a risk-off mood sometimes
when Bitcoin is getting hammered and
that could continue I am curious
throughout though we I mean we have seen
the correlations particularly this week
and last week uh really sort of move in
lockstep with regards to crypto and then
some of the other risk assets like
equities here and there are a lot of
people that used to talk about how
crypto could sort of be a hedge to some
of the normal Equity Market volatility
here if this court if this correlation
sort of persists here is that going to
create maybe a little bit further of a
ShakeOut is anyone talking about that
yet yeah
a little bit I think the the main thing
people are focused on is inflation and
are very much looking at signs of that
and you know there's a question of how
does Bitcoin react when we see further
inflation
um obviously we know that Tech doesn't
like measures of inflation Rising
um but it's I I think the idea of
Bitcoin as a hedge is still sort of
evolving and people are trying to figure
out what its price movement is
correlated with most often
as if banning Bitcoin mining wasn't
enough Chinese Regulators decided to ban
crypto trading completely in September
unlike previous bans on crypto
transactions the country's Central Bank
in cooperation with nine other
government agencies including the police
and the Supreme Court eliminated all
doubts about the country's attitude to
cryptocurrencies leaving absolutely
nothing for misinterpretation
The Regulators have classified all
crypto transactions both from crypto to
crypto and vice versa trading and
Investments as illegal regardless of
whether they were conducted through
local or foreign platforms
this includes all Bitcoin ethereum and
tether transactions Chinese Nationals
working in marketing or technical
support for foreign exchange may now
face prosecution the ndrc has outlined
plans to exit crypto mining completely
by seizing investment in the sector
increasing electricity costs and denying
new companies access to the industry
as Katie mentioned we've seen this story
play out somewhat before not too big of
a surprise still is this a is a pretty
big setback for the crypto community
you're right and thank you so much for
having me on this is not the first time
that Chinese Regulators have made such a
statement previous attempts to Outlaw
crypto really went nowhere I do think
that it's notable because it comes not
long after the miners fled inner
Mongolia so there's a bit more Dynamics
at play I think in regards to price
action and some of the the deeply rooted
fundamentals regarding the mining
and so Stefan I'm curious if you look at
the price action today you saw Bitcoin
drop close to nine percent but you saw
other coins really drop a lot more I
mean if I look at ether I think it got
close to around 11 or so I'm curious why
Bitcoin was the relative outperformer
this morning is it somewhat of a Haven
at this point
I think it's very reasonable to think
that uh that Bitcoin is a Haven I also
think that uh you know there's much more
of a fundamental thesis around Bitcoin
it's more mature assets so to see it
find kind of fundamental support you
know it is more is more understandable
people do have Financial metric sorry
fundamental metrics they apply to
bitcoin so they have their levels much
more so than I think they do in some of
these all coins that are a lot newer you
know they're based on you know highly
speculative use cases etc etc so I think
it makes sense in these sell-offs that
uh you know BTC which is uh you know
which I think you could make a lot more
fundamental Arguments for fines support
sooner and so Leah just again focusing
on the price action so even though this
wasn't new news you did see Bitcoin and
other cryptocurrencies react we are
heading into the weekend and we know
that the crypto markets are wide open
during the weekends and that it tends to
be a volatile time what are you
expecting what could we be uh waking up
to on on Monday morning
yeah absolutely well assets appear to
have found a floor but as you mentioned
weekends tend to be volatile and how
they react is definitely anyone's guess
but you know to your point you know
Bitcoin did drop about 10 before finding
resistance at about 40 000 recovering to
about 41 000 as mentioned it's sold off
about 10 as well remains well below 3
000 and those other old coins are down
even more however cardano did seem to
Surge higher on the news which is quite
interesting so I I think that it's it's
maybe anybody's guess but we'll have a
fun weekend for sure Savannah I'm
wondering about what this means for the
opportunity that other countries have if
China's cracking down could this be a
good thing for other countries
yeah I I mean I think that there was I
think one of their confusions around the
Chinese crypto Crackdown is that a lot
of uh you know about a year ago there
were a wave of crypto proponents that
suggested due to China's move into the
digital Yuan and the fact that they move
that ahead very quickly that they were
pro-crypto I mean I really don't believe
that that's ever been the case I mean as
as we know China's been trying to crack
on in crypto since 2013 they're a
country with strict foreign exchange
controls and for an asset class like
cryptocurrency which is promising more
Financial Freedom you know they've
always disliked it so you know I don't
think that this I I really don't think
this is an incremental shift in terms of
the opportunity set because China's
never wanted to be in crypto but perhaps
it'll change the perception in the US as
you mentioned earlier that hey you know
this is something we can get ahead of
China in and maybe that will be
something that uh that that pushes
Regulators to have uh you know more
favorable regulation towards the crypto
companies
um but yeah I don't think that I really
think that this is a rehasher prior of
Prior state minutes regulations you know
as Leah suggested so I I'm I'm not
saying this is changing the opportunity
set and in fact you know I think the
bigger news of the day was probably
positive which was uh which was the
Twitter launch
well yeah yeah go ahead go ahead Katie
no Tim why Stefan you talk a little bit
about that this idea that you can
actually tip using Bitcoin and through
through your Twitter account
yeah well I mean I think
yesterday we should know
yeah and uh exactly within that last
kind of 24 hours it's been enabled I
mean you're talking about if you're
we're thinking about
fundamental incremental increases in
Bitcoin usage right so we're saying that
you know people in China who have been
finding ways to use Bitcoin haven't been
allowed so call that flat no change
there and now we've got this uh you know
this very well-known high-profile firm
it's you that's applying Bitcoin for a
real use case I mean it's it's
definitely incremental to its utility
value as somewhat of and in addition to
that you know there's the there's so
many different Arguments for Bitcoin a
distort the store of value payment
mechanism this is kind of a you know A
New Concept and uh yeah I think it's
very interesting and and as Leah
mentioned as Leah mentioned we're we see
me finding some support here and perhaps
you know those those positive thoughts
will prevail and Leah's speaking of use
cases speaking of other countries I want
to quickly get your thoughts on El
Salvador because Bitcoin is actually
legal tender in El Salvador and I'm
curious if you have countries such as
China really trying to ban crypto
entirely it's another country's legal
tender how is that going to work
yeah very nuanced indeed I will just
note Stefan I agree with you I think
it's very exciting indeed that uh that
Twitter integrated not only just Bitcoin
tipping but also lightning
um to your point Katie this is
interesting I think because this saber
rattling from China comes at a time when
the digital one is starting to gain
Traction in regards to what you're
saying about El Salvador and why that
matters
um again the problem with declaring
Bitcoin illegal is that it's El
Salvador's National currency and people
who conduct business between the two
countries may be doing so in Bitcoin
um so I think that following El
Salvador's move to make Bitcoin its
National currency a number of other
nations including Costa Rica have been
making similar moves and statements a
number of other countries including
Ukraine and Cuba have either passed
crypto regulations or in the case of
Panama in the U.S are signaling that
those rules are soon to arrive so you
know I think what it comes down to is
markets have been made and there are
profits to be had I think it's very hard
to outlaw cryptocurrencies on a global
scale
despite China's severe Crackdown the
country has remained an important Global
crypto Market Chinese crypto wallets
have received coins worth around 150
million dollars so far this means China
remains second in the ranking following
the U.S according to a report by
analytics provider China allowances
[Music]
Henry Arslanian crypto leader at PWC
said most crypto exchanges overseas
still do not accept customers from the
US now exactly the same exchanges may
have to ban customers based in China as
well for most Global crypto exchanges
accepting customers from China has
always been a great market now that
ambiguity has been eliminated
but even if large exchanges are
forbidden to china-based Traders the
decentralized structure of the exchanges
makes it very difficult to stop people
from holding anything in any country
arslanion said the pboc is also
preparing to launch an official digital
rimin B making it a Pioneer in this
field
[Music]
the currency is to be launched in a
trial run during the 2022 Winter
Olympics Jason Guthrie head of digital
Investments at asset manager with the
mushri in Europe said China's attempt to
ban cryptocurrencies is just a
continuation of a trend but they are
intensifying the rhetoric ahead of the
launch of the digital reminbi
Edith young a partner at race Capital
talks to Bloomberg Technologies Emily
Chang about future strategies for
investing in China as the country faces
turbulence and how the recent Crackdown
can be a good thing for the crypto
ecosystem in the long term perspective
I'm curious for you as an investor how
this China checked Crackdown is
impacting your strategy and where you're
putting your money
well personally I take a very long-term
view on on China and obviously hearing
all these Crackdown news about China on
a daily basis almost but I do want all
investors to keep in mind that China is
the second still like the second largest
biggest Market in the world over 1.4
billion people 15 trillion GDP
um especially what I focus on in the
Venture space just look at Sequoia China
they did 96 deals in the last 90 days so
things definitely are not slowing down
per se but having said that of course
everyone in China needs to play by the
rules doesn't really matter that you
Alibaba made one or DD or even the bboc
or the cic no one can really outsmart or
outplay Chinese government but having
said that particularly on spec and exit
um really great to learn what's the
latest going on with SPAC
um actually one of my portfolio company
called DayDay cook mainly operates sort
of the tastemade of China they are
actually going on a spec on NASDAQ very
very soon merch with Ace Global and
that's still happening so in some sense
I think go ahead would you say would you
say have you changed your strategy at
all given the China Crackdown are you
putting in just as much money as you
would have or are you changing where
that money goes
um I really want to go back to China
because of covert I've been here for two
years now and not able to go back really
makes it really really tough for me to
invest in China mostly from a race
Capital strategy is to focus on early
stage put in early and support on
infrastructure software right now the
world is so big and everybody really
worked distributed and remotely so it
doesn't really matter and in China or
not but I have to say that most of the
reinvestment lately has been mostly in
Silicon Valley we invested in data
bricks we invested in FTX those are all
super Global and go to market in both
worlds well it's interesting that you
mentioned FTX because they recently
moved their headquarters from Hong Kong
to the Bahamas in part because of this
Crackdown and so I guess I'm curious
over the long term how do you see this
playing out in China I mean do you see
the Chinese government easing up on some
of these restrictions or
um if this is you know the long-term
strategy how do you think that impacts
the tech ecosystem there long term
I think Tech ecosystems need to play by
the rules it doesn't really matter how
big you are you have to comply by
Chinese law and especially recently with
this year the data privacy Protection
Law is key key thing I think as an
investor you need to be aware of that I
don't think we should drift our
investment strategy just because what's
happening in China but it's something
that we have to keep in mind there is
certainly still tons of upside because
the market is so big but then at the
same time there could be some ceiling
because what's going on I do think that
there's certain industries particularly
more more interesting for Venture
particularly on the Simon conductor and
healthcare because it's not really as
close to data consumer data which is
very very sensitive in China so
therefore
um being an investor you just we just
need to be super Nimble and pay
attention to what's going on in China
and what about crypto in particular I
mean you know trading mining in China
has become illegal so is crypto a more
extreme example how do you see the
Crackdown there in impacting the broader
landscape and investing
so China always have a love-hate
relationship with crypto
um and in 2008 um that's when I was
still going back to the China football
Force China was the number one in terms
of crypto Mining and what's the number
one in terms of crypto trading and since
2018 uh 2017 they've been Ico 2018
they've been Fiat to crypto trading
which then then you started to see
binance crypto to crypto trading in 2019
until today
um crypto mining has all been so in that
sense the biggest difference I do wanted
to point out is that when the first
crack then happened it really impacted
Bitcoin prices to about 3 000. today
according to um you know coin gecko it's
about 55 000 uh equivalent for Bitcoin
so I think that the Crackdown in China
on crypto in some sense is rebalancing
the crypto ecosystem and longer term is
actually a good thing
um for the blockchain ecosystem because
now China influence is actually getting
less and less
[Music]
in recent years it has become clear how
resolutely China is acting against
Bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies
while the policy of the People's
Republic with regard to BTC was
characterized by waiting and watching in
the first few years the negative
attitude seems to be manifesting itself
more and more due to the increasing
popularity of crypto
numerous sources point out that this
could have something to do with fighting
possible capital inflow
in addition it has been known for a long
time that China is working on its own
digital currency which is centrally in
the hands of the authorities and is
supposed to function in principle like
conventional Viet money only
electronically
as a news agency DPA reports the digital
yen is far advanced in its development
and is already being used in some areas
it is therefore not surprising that the
Chinese government is doing everything
it can to ban crypto competition
even during the pandemic of coronavirus
the Chinese government continue its
opposition to bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies and intensify its
Crackdown on illegal crypto activities
it has always claimed the fight against
fraud and money laundering as the reason
for its intense action more and more
foreign websites have been blocked by
crypto exchanges to prevent domestic
investors from Trading cryptocurrencies
and thus protect them from the risks of
unregulated trading in cyber currencies
even though cryptocurrencies always
react to every event described here with
strong price fluctuations bitcoin's
Rising Trends seems to be unbroken we
will have to wait and see whether it
continues to do so
[Music]